[Applauso]
Buonasera a tutti grazie essere qui è
bello vedere visi amici
Cosa succede se ci manca la paella
e se ci manca la padella
e se ci manca la Paideia la formazione
dell'uomo la formazione del suo sguardo
l'orientamento della sua anima
voglio raccontarvi due storie che ho
sentito dal canale del Ted
la prima
racconta della condizione umana
somigliante a uomini che fin da bambini
stanno incatenati sul fondo di una buia
caverna al collo e ai piedi non possono
né girarsi né camminare
guardano delle ombre transitare
proiettati da Oggetti che un fuoco che
arde dietro di loro Proietta
Che cosa sono queste ombre di manufatti
Beh potremmo dire forme culturali
anche libri di filosofia serie TV
romanzi visioni del mondo
Storia di un tizio che dal teatro di
Noventa vi parla del mito della caverna
sono proprio simili a noi dice glaucone
a Socrate nel Settimo libro della
Repubblica di Platone
Socrate poi che la voce narrante di
Platone ci racconta Che cosa accade ad
un prigioniero che venga ad un tratto
liberato la sua ascesa verso l'esterno
La luce del sole
Platone chiama il sole l'idea del bene
perché Perché il bene come la luce per
usare le parole di un pensatore
medievale Roberto grosso a testa è la
sua infinita manifestazione E pertanto
non c'è luce nel restare a fissare il
sole Platone in altri luoghi della sua
opera dice che chi resta lì a
contemplare il sole fa nei suoi occhi la
mezzanotte anziché il mezzogiorno cioè
resta cieco dice in altri luoghi della
sua opera che chi resta lì si brucia la
pelle Cioè ha una verniciatura di bene
ma non è buono il bene dice Platone come
le luci sta nella discesa ed è con
queste parole che inizia la Repubblica
di Platone con Socrate che scende al
Pireo il luogo del massimo caos la
nostra pancia la nostra sessualità il
caos della vita è lì dice Platone che il
bene si manifesta nella relazione agli
altri quindi la luce come il bene Ha a
che fare con l'altro ho sentito anche
un'altra storia
questa viene dalla tradizione del
buddismo Zen
racconta della condizione umana
assomiglia ad un pastore errante
dell'Asia che si è smarrito nel bosco
e alla ricerca del suo bufalo bue che ha
perduto Buffalo bue rappresenta la
natura di Buddha che significa le
dichiarazioni risveglio luce ad un certo
punto il pastore
scorge le tracce
scorge il bue lo addomestica lo cavalca
potremmo dire che a un certo punto se lo
magna perché non c'è più Cioè c'è una
incorporazione tra pastore 2 c'è una
vignetta vuota
che oggi non stiamo ad approfondire
Lasciamo la vostra curiosità e c'è un
incontro con la sorgente come nel mito
della caverna cioè sorgente della luce
Vi faccio notare che è presente anche
nella prima vignetta ma il pastore non
la vede e alla fine come nel mito
platonico c'è un ritorno nel mondo agli
altri di che cosa vi voglio parlare oggi
del punto più oscuro di entrambe le
storie proviamo a gettare luce a fare
luce in questo passaggio oscuro quale le
prime due vignette nel racconto buddista
Come mai ad un certo punto io giro lo
sguardo e la dispersione diventa una via
e per quanto riguarda la caverna di
Platone Come mai ad un certo punto il
prigioniero gira la testa
La caverna nella caverna gli uomini
vivono l'uno accanto all'altro non si
guardano mai Vivono in una guerresca
solitudine tant'è che verrebbe da usare
questo frammento di Eraclito che dice
gli uomini che dormono vivono Ognuno in
un mondo suo proprio
potremmo dire così la caverna è un mondo
dove ognuno vive in guerresca solitudine
con l'altro oppure giriamo le cause e
gli effetti è proprio perché viviamo
incatenati come direbbe il mio amico
Spinoso da passioni tristi l'odio
l'invidia la gelosia lavarizia che il
mondo è diventato una caverna
La caverna È un luogo in cui le anime
guardano avanti e conoscono dell'altro
soltanto i post sui social
l'ombra che Proietta e null'altro
E allora com'è che ci si libera
Platone nel mito della caverna non ce lo
dice però da altri luoghi dei dialoghi
di Platone
possiamo evincere due aspetti che hanno
a che fare con la luce Il primo è la
bellezza
La bellezza è un aspetto che splende
dice Platone nel Fedro che splende nel
buio
la bellezza nel cratilo un altro dialogo
di Platone
Il Socrate la fa derivare dal verbo
calein richiamare Allora la bellezza è
qualcosa che ci richiama e allora la
domanda è questa ma che cos'è che ci
richiama verso un orizzonte più ampio
più vasto più felice
E di ottima
è una filosofa presente nella Simposio
di Platone dice a Socrate che
l'esperienza della Bellezza assomiglia a
quella del grande mare del bello ma che
cos'è l'esperienza del grande mare del
bello immaginate di andare al mare o
anche una giornata sulla neve giornata
di sole che cosa vediamo sulla
superficie Marina vediamo brillare tutta
una serie di punti l'esperienza del
grande mare del bello è comprendere che
sono tutti legati
all'unità del Sole cioè sono riflessi
del sole
che cosa ancora vuol dire che sono
riflessi del sole anche qui Platone ci
dice che possiamo vederli come una
molteplicità senza legami
e usa due parole panna con buona pace
dei Fornai però Pan significa un mucchio
uomini che stanno assieme senza legarsi
pane significa come nel Simposio
pandemia parola che viene usata da
Platone cioè una bellezza che non ha
legami tra le parti proprio Platone usa
anche un altro termine olon laddove la
bellezza è un impero è legata
l'autore che
ho sentito più vicino per capire cosa
vuol dire una bellezza che ha dei legami
è Nietzsche Nizza in quest'opera è una
delle sue attuali Schopenhauer come
educatore ci dice così
guardati indietro giovane e anima Guarda
nella tua vita che cosa hai amato Che
cosa ti ha attratto e al contempo ti ha
reso felice bene smetti assieme tutti
questi oggetti scrive Nietzsche ed essi
ti mostreranno nella loro sequenza nella
loro successione del modo in cui uno
comprende Tra l'altro lo completa ti
mostreranno qualcosa del te stesso
perché te stesso scrive inizio e non sta
dentro di te ma sta fuori di te nel tuo
oltrepassamento E allora la domanda che
io ci Pongo è quali sono le cose che
così ci hanno legato quali sono quelle
cose belle che così ci hanno colpito
solo queste continua di ottima sono
maieutiche cioè sono generative ci fanno
rinascere dall'utero della caverna
Platone ci dice qualcos'altro
gli uomini nella caverna non si guardano
e quindi stanno nel buio dov'è che
trovano luce Platone in due luoghi
lettera settima e Alcibiade primo dice
che gli uomini possono fare luce quando
si guardano negli occhi e dialogano
filosoficamente in sincerità
Platone Usa questa bellissima immagine
come due legni che si sfregano si
accende una scintilla scocca nell'anima
e poi si nutre da se stessa
primo al CBR chiede a Socrate un giovane
politico rampante incontra Socrate gli
chiede ma come si fa a conoscersi e
Socrate risponde Come fa un occhio a
vedere se stesso
dovrebbe vedere una superficie nella
quale anche si riflette è l'occhio
dell'amico dice Socrate è nella Punto
vuoto della sua pupilla in quello spazio
lì di ascolto che io ho anche mi vedo e
cioè finalmente non sento più l'eco
della caverna ma la mia fonella la mia
voce
che è traccia della mia psiche della mia
anima
e quando Guarda Oriente Che cosa fa sì
che il pastore della prima vignetta che
vedete ha una distonia la testa guarda
Da una parte i piedi Sono direzionati
dall'altra Che cosa fa sì che si passi
da questa confusione alla via al camino
anche qui la tradizione non lo dice
esplicitamente però ce lo fa capire
attraverso almeno un aspetto importante
sedersi quietamente in silenzio dice
dogan grande maestro buddista giapponese
shican tasà mi siedo tranquillamente in
silenzio e che cosa succede se mi siedo
in silenzio
scopro la mia agitazione Allora qui il
risveglio è la coscienza del buio
la prima luce è che imparo a sapere di
non sapere socraticamente questo è il
primo inizio
L'inizio è sono cosciente che mi sono
smarrito e quindi Ricerco se non c'è
questa mancanza epnia non c'è non c'è la
via Cioè non c'è Eros non c'è desiderio
che cosa sente L'uomo che si siede in
silenzio in Ana panasati cioè
nell'ascolto del respiro
scopre la sua condizione Buddismo la
Chiama Di Duca viene tradotto con
sofferenza ma che cos'è Lucca
Duca è letteralmente
il rumore di una ruota che non è ben
oliata
proviamo a trattenere il respiro 5
secondi
ecco chi ha fatto ne hanno faccia il
figo per favore però
stiamo male
questo dolore
si chiama Duca perché stiamo male perché
noi non vediamo a vda non vediamo che la
realtà è nata Anita dice Buddismo Cioè
non è mia perché respiro è una relazione
non è mia e quando io prendo qualcosa
come un possesso sto male perché non
vedo non ho chiaro non ho Bud che la
cosa è relazione e poi è
impermanente quando io trattengo
qualcosa che non ha la natura di essere
trattenuto sto male E allora trattengo
le offese trattengo le cose passate e
così via Cioè mi afferri
Non a caso quella che vi ho mostrato
prima Adesso andiamo un attimo nel
dettaglio la bava Chakra la ruota
dell'esistenza gira gira quando si
inceppa Duca
Che cos'è che la fa inceppare la prima
vignetta cioè diciamo la numero uno nel
senso cronologico dell'orologio è
rappresentata da una vecchia cieca è una
pensionata di Praga per capirci che va
dritta verso un burrone a Vidia non vede
e questo non vedere che mette in moto la
ruota della Sofferenza questo mettere in
moto la sofferenza si chiama Sam Sara
girare assieme fermarlo Nirvana Come
faccio a fermarlo la tradizione buddista
dice attraverso la pratica
e che cos'è la pratica sedersi in
silenzio ascoltare il respiro
c'è un passaggio importante dall'opera
di doghe Che ci racconta una storia c'è
un discepolo che va dal maestro il
maestro è lì meditazione ha un ventaglio
in mano discepolo dice maestro A cosa
serve il ventaglio la natura del vento
esiste è in ogni luogo
è maestro risponde Tu sai soltanto che
in ogni luogo ma come facciamo a
rivelare il vento
discepolo dice facciamo rivelare il
vento il maestro si sventola discepolo
si inchina e se ne va Doga invece
la pratica dello Star seduto in silenzio
non è
come dire la sala d'attesa del risveglio
è rischieramento è l'agitazione del
ventaglio cioè il movimento del mio
corpo e l'attenzione al respiro che mi
rischiara Cioè che cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che non devo pensare che ci sia un
mondo liberato Nirvana e questo è un
mondo di sofferenze ma devo imparare a
cambiare i miei sguardo O come dice in
maniera meravigliosa lascia Mana nella
principessa mononoke di Miyazaki dovrà
imparare a vedere il mondo con occhi non
offuscati dall'odio dalla sofferenza
e così abbiamo fatto passare immagini di
manufatti è passata l'immagine del
manufatto delle opere di Platone è
passata l'immagine del manufatto della
tradizione buddista E che cosa sono
queste immagini compresa questa è che
viene narrata
Platone dice
le immagini possono avere diversa natura
ci sono i fantasmi sono immagini prive
di consistenza
slegate dalle cose vere legate dalle
cose belle slegate dalle cose giuste poi
ci sono gli idoli di ce Platone sono
immagini autoreferenziali
che non mostrano altro Rispetto a sé e
infine ci sono le icone che sono
immagini di luce e la loro natura dice
Platone sta nel rimandare ad altro
ora
è importante per fare luce incontrare le
icone sì
è importante la pratica del dialogo
filosofico con gli amici Sì è importante
l'incontro con la bellezza certo È
importante anche l'attenzione al respiro
senza dubbio sono tutte necessarie per
fare luce ma non sono sufficienti
perché manca il nostro inizio
Il nostro passo lo dobbiamo fare noi
abitatori della caverna
pastori smarriti
perché per provare dal buio della
caverna a riuscire a veder le stelle
grazie
[Applauso]